a hugh jackman side that's a good one
right yeah
let's serve up some news sunny side up
our next listing went viral because it's
just oozing with 1970s charm the new
haven register reports that this four
bedroom in fort wayne indiana is covered
in
wall to wall shag carpet all
2476 square feet designed in 1975 by
architect james
sherbondi the carpets and stains are
all original oh the stains are original
drew's in
i know by the way i'm like let me at
this house with a bottle of draft
a family from orlando put in an offer
before stepping
foot into the place damn natasha
thoughts
and this house is kind of looking to me
like ross matthews house if he never
left his hometown
you don't even know how dead on that is
right i actually was looking at those
pictures of me thinking to myself like
it's not bad i'm kind of into it i mean
look that house for starters those lines
that's beautiful the carpet is
literally hot watermelon color i mean
the shot goes up to the edge of the tub
can you imagine
that that carpet has never been changed
even imagine what is inside that carpet
i don't want to
forbes report that smash hits hamilton
wicked and the lion king are all
officially reopening on
september 14th and right behind them
yes right behind these icons
is also some super fresh new exciting
shows
six very exciting this is a huge play
uh about henry the eighth wives
oh wow um yeah and this is like the it
show and it's finally coming to new york
on september 17th there's so much buzz
about it
it's bananas um you've got one to tear
talk about we'll miss a doubtfire hello
drive by fruiting
uh it's in previews on october 21st we
can't wait to see that uh
the music man with hugh jackman will
finally start previews
and sutton foster yes side note i was at
dinner the other night and hugh jackman
was
right over there i know oh my god a hugh
jackman side
that's a good one right yeah yeah i was
so nervous um there's also
beetlejuice um dear evan hansen's coming
back
ross did you know that one third of all
food
goes to waste one-third no i didn't is
that true
it is depressingly true wow once it hits
the landfill
all that food is responsible for eight
percent of all greenhouse gas emissions
worldwide well there is really
interesting news i'm very excited about
this story
there's a brand new app that's tackling
this
the good news network reports that too
good to go
lets you buy leftovers from your
favorite restaurants before they get
thrown out
the app is already in 15 countries and
spreading throughout the u.s it shows
which restaurants near you
have leftovers and you can buy them at a
deep discount
and then you show up at your designated
pickup time
with your reusable bag and collect your
food
you are truly saving whatever is a
surplus
and you get a surprise every time i mean
i am so moved by this story this is this
is all you drew because it's like
one it's like um it's
the consumer doing one thing to make
such a huge difference right and this
time the consumer's winning because
they're getting a good deal i mean these
prices are cut like
big time down there's major discounts
food is not getting wasted
there he goes there's the doggie and
today the perfect
sunnies to accessorize for your summer
oh yeah
baby candy colored rimless sunglasses i
actually wore these um
on our wildflower shoot those look so
cute look
oh something they look cute on you look
at me they look cute
they look so good on your ross they're
ultra light
ultra cute and they come in this huge
variety of colors on amazon
and they protect you uva and uvb
um ross what color oh you're yeah let's
just
throw as many as you can on i'm wearing
blue but i want to look at life through
rose colored glasses now look
i'm going to go like a light coca-cola
heel
i look like elton john you look so cute